politics was always in the room
who mission chief reflects on china trip
seeking cobia 19's origin so this is an
interview
by by science one of the two most
important scientific journals in the
world
with uh the mission leader peter ben and
barack who we haven't heard as much from
because peter dashek was sort of the
i don't know self-appointed otherly
appointed spokesperson mostly
um but let us
just go to a few of these questions
here we go question at friday's press
conference in geneva ted rose seemed to
contradict you by saying that with
respect to the origins of sarsko v2
quote all hypotheses around the table
was it a mistake to call the
lab origin hypothesis extremely unlikely
embark answers no
we first developed a pathway of all the
possible ways the virus could be
introduced into the human population in
late 2019
a lab accident is one hypothesis another
is the direct introduction from an
animal host and others are different
versions of intermediary hosts
for each hypothesis we tried to put
facts on the table look at what we had
in terms of arguments and then make an
assessment of each
it was already a big step to have
chinese colleagues assess and evaluate
such a hypothesis based on what we had
on the table which was not much
yes lab accidents do happen around the
world they have happened in the past
the fact that several laboratories of
relevance are in and around wuhan and
are working with coronavirus is another
fact
beyond that we didn't have much in terms
of looking at that hypothesis is a
likely option
so like asterisk yes you did but okay
let's go back into the interview for a
moment
question and but what led you to use the
extremely unlikely label did you learn
anything that made it less likely
answer again in barack speaking we
should not put too much focus on the
wording
we were looking at different options at
some point we were thinking should we
use a ranking with one being the most
unlikely five the most likely or should
we use colors
or should we find another scale we ended
up with a five phrase scale extremely
unlikely unlikely possible likely and
very likely
it's more an illustration of where these
hypotheses are to help us organize our
planning of future studies
question but my question is whether you
learned anything new in china
now that you've been there do you have
more reason to say it's extremely
unlikely than before
translation answer my damn question dude
answer
again embark yes we had long meetings
with the staff of the woohoon institute
of virology in three other laboratories
and we
can't even do this with a straight face
um they talked about these claims openly
we discussed what did you do over the
past year to dismiss this claim
what did yourself develop in terms of
argumentations did you do audits
yourself did you look at your records
did you test your staff
and they explained how they worked and
what kind of audit system they had
they had retrospectively tested serum
from their staff they tested samples
from early 2019 from 2020.
there were a lot of discussions that we
could not have had if we had not
traveled to wuhan
we also did not have evidence provided
by outsiders to support any of the
claims out there
that could potentially have tipped the
balance what we saw and discussed gave
us much more confidence in our
assessment
the consensus was that this is an
unlikely scenario
we also had difficulties designing
future studies to look into the
laboratory claims within our joint group
because if you want to explore such a
hypothesis further
you need a different mechanism you need
to do a formal audit
and that's far beyond what our team is
mandated to do or has the tools and
capabilities to do
so that was also a reason why we could
not start moving forward in our next
series of studies into that direction
but the fact that the hypothesis is
listed or assessed as extremely unlikely
is not the same as if it had been listed
or assessed as impossible
we're not closing the door
we're not closing the door because it's
swollen and we can't get it to close
um oh my god yeah i mean it's it's
really it's like
and you're like sorry but like well we
looked at a number of different schemes
you know probably you wouldn't be upset
with us if we just said it was purple
instead of a highly unlikely like you
know we we thought about using language
then we thought about using colors and
we thought about using like
just because we landed on this scheme
doesn't really mean anything
what are you talking about i thought
about having a guy with a uniform stand
there and say nothing to see here folks
go on home
yeah don't look be i look don't look at
the man behind the curtain don't look at
them
there's infinite numbers of versions of
like what are you doing you're not
compelling
this is not a compelling interview now
interestingly
um let us compare this hey zach you want
to put up the uh
i sent you a paper this is not a
peer-reviewed paper but it takes the
form of a manuscript and it is by
um authors who actually have advanced
a uh so this is latham and wilson
wilson uh and this paper
is basically an analysis of how
likely it is that china uh
that there is a natural origin
intermediate to be found which was
a large part of the discussion that we
did last week
and they attempt to quantify the chances
and
actually this analysis although i'm
going to argue that it is
flawed i think it is flawed in a way
that the natural scientific process
would cause their estimate to be refined
but the analysis centers on some very
interesting
and important pieces of evidence one of
them being
phylogenetic and the other geographic
okay right
and the point is the point of the
analysis is
that if you
look at the chances of patient zero
showing up in
wuhan and the chances that the
coronavirus that becomes a pandemic
is a beta coronavirus
from this particular group that is to
say from the same group
as generated sars cove uh one
the initials uh sars that the chances
they calculate the chance if you scroll
down here zach
scroll down to near the end of the
article they calculate
the number if you combine the like oh
there it is
um one in 630
that it will be in wuhan and 1 in 28
that it will be
a close relative of the original sars
and they calculate the combined number
at one in 17 640.
now i think their number is probably off
by an order of magnitude
but you know it is nonetheless
an impressive degree and you know at
some point i wouldn't mind
talking with the authors of this about
how i would alter their methodology
to make it more robust but the point is
the the likelihood calculation
is so far away that they actually
conclude
if you can go back to it um in the next
paragraph
here uh there the last sentence of the
next paragraph says a lab escape should
at this point
be the default hypothesis was which
people who listened last week will
remember
was one of the arguments that we made
that which is that effectively
because there is substantial evidence
for a laboratory leak and because
there is not evidence of a natural
intermediate that in fact lab leak
has the status of the null hypothesis at
this point in other words it is possible
it came from nature but that puts the
burden
on those who would argue that to find
the intermediate and absent that
intermediate the one plausible
intermediate that we have
is the laboratory yeah i'm actually so i
don't i'm not familiar with this paper
this is the first time i've seen it but
i'm liking
what i see here actually the first part
of that paragraph you just read the last
sentence from
the criticism will that less be made
that the geographic and the phylogenetic
evidence described here are
circumstantial
mere coincidences but critiquing
evidence is circumstantial is based on a
common logical misconception
that circumstantial evidence represents
a special category of evidence
as the philosopher david hume first
argued all evidence of causation is
composed of coincidences
all an observer can do is to add up the
coincidences until they surmise at the
threshold of reasonable doubt has been
surpassed
conclusions are always provisional but
in the absence of evidence to the
contrary
anyone open to persuasion on at this
point to conclude the probability of
seventeen thousand six hundred forty to
one far exceeds that threshold
a lab escape should this point be the
default hypothesis now i see there that
they've alighted a key
part of the scientific process in their
description there right like that
um if you have the hypothesis before you
find
the um the you know we have talked about
this with regard to correlation and
causation right like
um correlation does not imply causation
unless you predicted it in advance
right and so their their sort of
approach from from
hume centric as opposed to more like
bacon francis bacon-centric which is you
know our
sort of original um approach um
converge i think right and so they land
as well
on this conclusion this concludes what
the default should be and default
the uh so this makes so many of the
right points because
for one thing uh people who've been with
these live streams since the beginning
will remember
the very early period as we were trying
to sort out what we were
learning about coronavirus and the field
all of the fields involved in this
discussion had moved into a mode
where because there wasn't time for
normal peer review you couldn't wait a
year for your paper to go through
that process yeah we were just working
from the stuff on the archives right
now the stuff on the archives is the
pre-print servers so archive was
the name of one of the pre-servers the
pre-print servers which are not yet
peer-reviewed
basically it's a place to lodge papers
to take the right form but haven't been
through that process
but it made for a a very
vibrant discussion in which many more
people had
access to the tools it was messy there
was lots of wrong stuff
there right so it didn't have the kind
of quality control
that comes from peer review but the
quality control that comes from peer
review is
anything but a hedge against bad
information making into the literature
there's tons of bad information
and increasingly as we've talked about
before here peer review acts as these
latter day fact checkers where they're
motivated to um you know to a particular
kind of research
type of conclusion people in particular
that they want to have published et
cetera
right now what i would point out is that
this paper which as far as i know
is not peer-reviewed it takes the form
of a peer-reviewed paper but it's
published in a source that doesn't peer
review i think
um it is
uh logically evaluatable
i have concerns about the way it was
done and one of the conclusions is
interesting so these people advanced
a hypothesis earlier that the
intermediate was the
one of the minors in the uh the yunnan
mine from which samples were taken and
they have a a model in which the lungs
of that minor basically served as a
serial passage experiment
now i don't think this can be the case
but it is a viable hybrid one of the
miners who died
or one of them i actually don't think it
matters
i don't think we know what we don't have
is any evidence that those miners
transmitted the virus to anybody
um so if it you know if it is a lab
so their their idea is it's a lab leak
and that the sample was transmitted to
the lab from which it leaked but the
sample
was enhanced in the lungs of these
miners through a natural evolutionary
process
i don't believe that this can be the
case why uh
well for a number of reasons one um
i believe that the selection a i don't
believe that there's enough room for
that selection to have taken place
um in a single individual but there are
well and this is part of why i asked you
one of the ones who i
as i understood it i thought that there
were only you know a handful of people
who got it and they all died
six three done okay so you know this
would this
seems more plausible to me if it's the
la
from the lungs of one of the miners who
survived and therefore it may have had
more
um basically more generations in which
to
in which to evolve within the lungs of
that minor yeah i agree
although if we're talking about sars
kovi ii
um you know then we're talking about
something that the immune system does
get wise to
and you know ultimately wins that battle
so anyway we can talk about i agree that
if you lived there was a longer period
of time potentially
for that evolution to take place but i
don't believe a single miner's lungs
are going to be enough i remain to be
convinced of whether that's true but
here's the other problem is that there
are two factors
in the um
the amazing capacity of sars kovi ii at
the point it shows up and hits the
ground running in wuhan
right it's very good at invading tissues
and it's very good at getting between
individuals
and all of the selection in the miner's
lungs would have been in favor of
invading tissues it would not be super
well adapted
and as far as we know it didn't go
between tissues either
it didn't go between individuals didn't
go between tissues well that would
certainly be an interesting question i
don't think we know that that's true
because they died of what was called uh
i don't think it was even called
viral pneumonia was understood to be a
pneumonia we now know it was a viral
pneumonia
um but uh it would be very interesting
to know
you know what a full uh necropsy would
would have revealed about um
what other tissues were affected yeah
there's a lot that could be
settled if we had uh those samples which
i believe we just simply don't and they
might actually exist in somebody's
freezer somewhere which is another
reason that we need to
answer this this question right but
nonetheless
these authors say
they do exactly the right thing they lay
out all of their work
right that work can be evaluated i
believe that they're off
by something like a factor of 10 which
still leaves a
very impressive you know one thousand
seven hundred and sixty to one
uh burden which is way um
or uh indication of direction
which is you know i've only gone i've
said i think it's 90
or above that's well above that um but
in any case
the natural process can now unfold here
outside of those who would fetter the
conversation
right we can yeah darn those federers
um i always liked how he played well i
mean he's gifted but uh
but nonetheless he's not a uh he's not a
hero of free speech
he might be i don't know sorry roger
that that was uncalled for on my part as
far as i know
you might be a hero free spiritual i'm
just not not aware of it but
in any case we can now have the
discussion and say look here's how i
would modify your method so that your
approximation of the chances of this
having happened uh by random would be
uh more accurate might be i'm wrong
we'll find out
you know might be there wrong they
adjust their number we could get a
better number but the point is it's
still a pretty impressive
the analysis itself you know how you uh
numeritize it is that a word no no
okay i propose numeritize becomes a word
but uh
uh but it okay how do you multiply it
how you quantify it um
it's an open question but the analysis
itself uh
is i believe logically robust and very
persuasive
and it suggests the burden of proof
therefore you know we are both you don't
see any sign errors you think the
the the size of the of
the estimate is off i think the size of
the estimate is off but the point is
it's uh
the estimate is so profound that even at
a tenth their strength it's still
uh overwhelming remarkable um and then i
think the question about you know they
say there are four
lab league hypotheses it is very likely
that
their their estimate on um the strength
of that likelihood
is that it is one of these and their
point is we have advanced
one it could be any of the four or
another but um
it's likely to be in that quadrant and
not a natural origin and that is
certainly an excellent place to have a
high quality scientific discussion
you